bei uns im studio ist unser politik chef
jan schäfer jan wir fragen uns natürlich
alle wie kann es eigentlich sein es ist
die route momentan alle kommen und
niemand tut was ja guten morgen ja wir
sehen in der tat das wie hieß es gerade
eben schon so schön gestern abend auch
bei die richtigen fragen vom sächsischen
innenminister dass die außengrenze der
eu löchrig ist wie ein schweizer käse
und das passt den spätes gab im sommer
im juno vom europäischen rechnungshof
eine studie zu der arbeit der
europäischen grenzagentur frontex also
wie gut ist sie eigentlich was den
schutz der eu außengrenzen angeht und
das war ein vernichten der bericht das
war ein vernichten der beitrag in dem
ganz klar auch hergestellt und gezeigt
wurde dass eben frontex also diese
grenzschutzagentur ihrem auftrag nicht
nachkommt ja und dann ist natürlich das
problem jetzt wieder da viele viele
flüchtlinge kommen und können gar nicht
richtig gestoppt werden wir können ja
noch mal auf die szene die meisten
hängengeblieben ist in der reportage von
peter wilke schauen da sieht man also
wie geflüchtete nachts die deutsch
polnische grenze passieren und einfach
an einer polizeiwache vorbeilaufen die
beamten dürfen nicht eingreifen sie
dürfen sie nicht am grenzübertritt
hindern denn wir sind ja im schengenraum
und erst am bahnhof wurden dann die vier
jungen männer
abgefangen die bilder zeigen also die
schwierige situation in der einerseits
die geflüchteten stecken die eigentlich
weiterziehen wollen und jetzt erstmal
den erstaufnahmestellen verweilen müssen
aber eben auch die schwierige situation
der polizeibeamten bin in dieser
situation die hände gebunden sind was
tun ja es heißt aber eigentlich auch
wenn man nach deutschland kommt und hier
einen asylantrag stellen möchte da muss
man als allererstes oder direkt
eigentlich eine dienstliche eine eine
behörde auf suche in dem fall wäre das
natürlich dann die station auch der
bundespolizei gewesen also so einfach
kann man sich dann glaube ich nicht
machen und wir sehen natürlich hier ein
kernproblem wir sind innerhalb der eu in
einem schengen raum ganz klar dort soll
es keine grenzkontrollen geben aber das
setzt natürlich voraus dass die
grenzkontrollen im außenbereich der eu
funktionieren also dass die eu das
beispielsweise polen aber auch italien
griechenland dass diese länder ganz
genau wissen wer in den deutschen in den
eu raum kommt und damit auch
möglicherweise nach deutschland kommen
kann und das ist etwas was auch mehrmals
immer wieder in den vergangenen wochen
monaten und jahren kritisiert wurde
genau das leistet frontex auch nicht
genau hier gibt es immer wieder
informationsdefizite und dann gibt es
solche bilder wie wir es jetzt gerade
gesehen haben und dann glaubst du
schuldigen sondern das glaubst du wie
wird es weitergehen wie viele werden
noch kommen was erwartet uns noch wir
befinden uns jetzt gerade in deutschland
natürlich in einer problematischen
situation es gibt eine bundesregierung
die abgewählt wurde die ist nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt und da gibt es
eine möglicherweise neue bundesregierung
bestehend aus spd grünen und fdp
politikern die aber noch nicht mal einen
koalitionsvertrag hat es gibt auch noch
keinen neu gewählten bundeskanzler olaf
scholz also von daher ist das eine in
between situation möchte ich mal sagen
gerade jetzt in dieser aktuellen
flüchtlingskrise die wir wieder sehen
ist das natürlich ein echtes problem
weil die eine regierung quasi
handlungsunfähig ist die neue regierung
noch nicht steht und in dieser zeit der
migrationsdruck nach deutschland
trotzdem massiv zunimmt also was tun
mein vorschlag wäre die nächste
bundesregierung die ampel koalition muss
sich wirklich beeilen muss aufs tempo
drücken damit dieses problem möglichst
schnell jetzt in den griff bekommt
werden kann